THE DUCKS.
KEVIN
TAMP. IT BACK
HE SHOWED IT THERE.
GOOD SPEED, GREAT RELEASE. IING.
5.
IN COMES HENRIQUE.
KNOCKED DOWN BY MILLER.
LONG SHOT.
OF MAYBE SECOND.
DRYSDALE'S PASS HIT
MIKA ZIBANEJAD SAID IT I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY TIMES.
WHAT A PASS.. DOUBLE-TEAMED.
MILLER TRYING TO FIND THE PUCK.
DOES. FOUND FRONT.
I DON'T THINK GEORGIEV SAW THAT.
IT LOOKED LIKE STROME.
PUCK COMES OUT OF THE
LA FORTY-TWO NEAR TURNS IT IS W
AND GREAT HANDS OF ZEGRAS AND
NEMETH STAYED WITH HIM.
>> Sam: : RARA CHYTIL ON TO BLO
DOWN THE BOARDS..
SCHNEIDER CAME BACK.
HE TRIED TO GET THE STICK.D PEN.
RANGERS SCORED ON A DELAYED
PENALTY EARLY IN THE
EVENTUALLY, THERE IS CHRIS
KREIDER.
HE'S IN
SAVE BY GEORGIEV HE'S HAD.
ANAHEIM 9-10 IN